it's a normal afternoon on the doorstep
of San Francisco's main government
building a snapshot of America's
fentanyl crisis
it doesn't just look Stark
an average of one person every 10 hours
dies in this city of a fentanyl overdose
it's often here in the drug ravaged
tenderloin District
are you a fentanyl user absolutely I've
been in here I've been an opiate addict
for probably 10 years Trevor used to
inject heroin but fentanyl he says is a
different beast and he wants everyone to
know I mean the fact that this isn't a
main issue I mean on TV every night is
insane to us I've never seen anything
like it I meet regular people Square
Joe's on their way to work and they'll
stop hang out with me and try this drug
for the first time and then leave their
life literally not not leave from that
moment on they're just out here with us
is that what fentanyl does to some
people it's insane I've never seen
anything like it no one has what's it
doing to the streets
is turning everybody into you know a
crazy violent drug addict we're doing an
interview I know but do that somewhere
else y'all smoking crack right here
daycare right there we're interrupted by
Private Security asking them to move out
of the view of the nursery
this is a city divided on how to deal
with the scourge of drugs
some want the streets swept others
prefer a more compassionate health-based
approach
no one wants to end up with a
manslaughter charge because someone dies
from their product Jeff is a former drug
dealer and says testing is the answer
two stripes would be a negative result
one one trade would be a positive result
yep so there's a second line showing up
right now simple strip tests are now
being used by dealers and users to check
for fentanyl it sometimes contaminates
Other Drug supplies Like Cocaine I know
you work with one of the largest Mexican
street gangs helping test their cocaine
to make sure it doesn't have fentanyl or
traces of fence on it how how does that
work yeah
customers start to notice that people
are dying from a batch of cocaine and
that the autopsy results are showing
that it's because of an opioid overdose
no one's buying that cocaine anymore I
mean it just doesn't make Financial
sense to kill your customer base
across town beside a homeless encampment
a charity has set up
they hand out clean syringes and
overdose reversal treatments how has
fentanyl transformed your home people
are dying a lot more people are dying
and and it's in a lot of the drug Supply
and people are doing it without knowing
they're doing it and it's it's made
substance use
um
horrifyingly
deadly
it's difficult to believe at times that
this is one of America's great historic
cities home to more billionaires than
anywhere on Earth
this is two streets from the
headquarters of Twitter but it's an
open-air drug Market it is a tragedy
with no easy resolution